[Music]
the 11 week old prince was the star of
the day Duchess Kate glowed in a
cream-colored Alexander McQueen dress
while carrying her sleeping son Prince
William was on daddy duty holding the
hands of Louie's older siblings Prince
George and Princess Charlotte Megan was
elegant in a pale olive green Ralph
Lauren dress and fascinator by Stephen
Jones she and Prince Harry arrived
showing some PDA by holding hands we
don't really see William and Kate do it
but we do see Harry and Megan do it
that's their style there's no etiquette
as such if they feel like holding hands
then no one's going to tell them not to
but I do think we see them on more
formal behaviour when they're with the
Queen little Louie has six godparents
and the group does not include Megan and
Harry for all three of their children
rather than ask extended family members
they basically asked close friends their
sort of rule of thumb has been friends
over family a notable absence the babies
great grandparents where was the Queen I
think on this one the Queen decided that
she was going to graciously bow out she
has got quite an important visit coming
up at the end of the week Donald Trump
coming to visit the Queen at Windsor
Duchess Kate's sister Pippa showed off a
bit of a baby bump while arriving with
her husband James Matthews tomorrow
Megan and Harry begin a trip to Ireland
marking the Duchess's first overseas
trip since becoming a member of the
royal family we're going to see how they
are as a married couple as a team how
they're received and yep sets the tone
for the future they want to roll up
their sleeves and get ready for work
let's be honest we're all just waiting
for that announcement when Megan barkal
says he's pregnant
[Music]